and i'm very pleased to say that uh
teresa coffey a work and pensions
secretary is here with me now um welcome
to you first of all good morning we just
ran through the latest growth figures
they show a contraction for the last
three months um a sign perhaps of what's
to come
warnings of a deep recession heading our
way as well so in the midst of all of
this
where is the government
well it is concerning and of course the
bank of england also forecast a deeper
recession than perhaps have been
anticipated as well and that's why we
need i think with liz's prime minister
to change course and to get a plan for
growth uh an element of reducing taxes
both for working people but also not
putting up more corporation taxes which
can be a drain on investment into into
companies and businesses and people in
order to get that growth so i am
concerned about it but nevertheless we
have to keep to try
and make sure we do what we can to get
rid of unnecessary regulations
particularly those from the eu okay to
get britain moving again that's liz
truss's plans for the future you're in
the government now why is the government
not doing more now to lay out plans to
help people well in terms of in june we
legislated for a package of support um
just about 15 billion pounds this year
and that is already underway my own
department was giving support to people
on benefits last month we started doing
the first part of the cost of living
payment and of course things are
changing that's why government is
getting ready the prime minister met
energy companies yesterday we're already
doing work but of course we need to wait
formally for off gem to report at the
end of the month and then we can take
further steps potentially
but i think importantly overall
we um this reason i'm supporting liz is
to get that growth is to make sure that
people have more money in their own
pocket instead of waiting for government
to do these schemes and pay people back
okay and i'll come on to those plans a
little bit later but i'm talking about
right now you mentioned that meeting
yesterday with boris johnson and some of
the energy chiefs but they weren't all
there were they some of the big players
weren't there bp and shell weren't there
at the end of it no announcement no
action taken so what was the point of it
was it all about being seen to be doing
something i think it's recognizing that
of course uh uh what people rely on in
terms of uh some of the changes that may
need to be made it's important that the
prime minister the chancellor and the
energy secretary have those direct
conversations
um it's uh i'm very conscious of the
ongoing investment that still needs to
be made in the energy industry
in order to help us move towards net
zero in the future but understandably
right now some of our challenges are
global uh but some of our challenges we
need to make sure we increase the energy
security and resilience of this country
so we're not reliant
on just uh what was happening to world
gas prices
but also further changes that may be
needed in the market and the regulation
as well well yes i'm sure they're
important discussions that are being had
but don't people deserve to know now
whether or not they're going to be
facing higher bills with with no support
in the autumn i mean a lot of people are
very anxious and very stressed some of
the most vulnerable people people that
you represent as uh work and pensions um
secretary don't they need to have some
action spelled out now
well we have already set in place i took
legislation through parliament in june
and we've already started making those
payments every household will be getting
support next month toward their cost of
their bills well i'm conscious that uh
people may are seeing these numbers in
the news um offgem is uh due to report
at the end of this month i think it's
important to say government is working
already to consider potential options
that could be taken forward
in order to potentially offer more
support but overall as i say the
approach from the person i want to be
the next prime minister is to allow
people to keep more of their own money
so removing that national insurance
increase making sure that's in their
pockets rather than coming into
government and then coming back out
through schemes as a general approach
but nevertheless there is support right
now and if if we are going to change
that
then i would need to take further
legislation through parliament
in the autumn to do make any changes how
does the reversal of the national
insurance rise help the most vulnerable
how does it help people on benefits how
does it help pensioners how does it help
people that don't earn enough to qualify
to pay it in the first place well in
terms of people on very low incomes
they're already part of the support
package that is uh there now
as i say which falls short of the the
rises that we're anticipating in energy
price well indeed and um you know richie
sunaku and his chancellor set this on
the basis of future forecasts
of where we would be i appreciate we're
in a different place now but i wasn't
given powers to be able to make ad-hoc
changes to
payments that we were to be given out
that wasn't allowed within government so
we set forward our legislation and
that's why if you know the options that
need to be considered uh are being uh
drawn up now but it's important that we
wait for that aspect from off gen just
like we did in the past and came forward
with appropriate support but the overall
focus i think for future is about how we
can reduce taxes
keep more money in people's pockets but
nevertheless the government just as it
has in the past is there and all options
will be considered all options will be
considered will there be direct
intervention to help the worse off under
a liz trust government where she to win
well we've already had um direct
intervention we have that's underway and
still
more money is more money is still due to
come through
and that is already in train for more
money to go to every household but it's
important that uh liz makes that if she
is the prime minister gets those options
that were are being worked up across
government and makes that uh considered
approach and you know liz represents a
constituency where the average earnings
or median earnings are lower than that
in the city of liverpool she knows what
it's like for hardworking households who
are struggling with cost of living i've
experienced that in my role as an mp as
well as being secretary of state for
work and pensions and that's why these
measures are being worked up and they
will be considered but it's important
instead of making policy on the hoof
that uh you know a considered prime
minister will
work wait for the advice that comes and
then be able to make a judgment on what
uh it needs to be done and what level of
support may be needed okay well let's
look at benefits because that's your
remit
will liz trust use
universal credit could she be prepared
to use universal credit as a way to help
out some of the poorer households when
they're hit by these higher bills her
own campaign manager ian duncan smith
told us on this program yesterday that
he thinks it's the best way to offer
support for the most vulnerable rishi
sunak wants to use the benefit system
that way too so why
well we already are we already are using
the benefit system and that will be one
of the options that is being considered
and as i say the next prime minister
will need to make a judgment on what
levers to use and what level of support
to be offered but as i say we've already
paid out to over 7 million people just
last month part of the cost of living
payment more is coming uh next month uh
whether it's for all households for
pensioners for people with disabilities
so it's a package that is gradually
being rolled out but i understand and
this is why government is working on
options but it's important that that is
done in a considered way thinking about
the different levers thinking about
whether reducing people's corporate uh
income tax is uh the quickest way or
indeed removing the national insurance
increases that have been uh increased
are still a possibility absolutely every
option will be considered in terms of uh
support schemes that may be needed in a
whether it's a targeted way or the
general way of reducing uh that removing
that national insurance increase uh
which liz is absolutely committed to do
in an emergency budget but people have
to wait and see for at least another
month whether they'll get help or not if
list trusts were to win well people are
going to get help i think it's about
what change and help may be needed but
help is already being given and will be
given in the future as well
we're seeing extraordinary temperatures
across the country for the second time
in a month we're also seeing
drought conditions across many parts of
the country as well is this climate
change
i think it's uh certainly
more evidence if people needed it of the
impact of what is happening when extreme
weather events with our gradually
changing climate change which is why
it's important to keep our focus on
achieving net zero but in the short term
in terms of we've seen an increase in
investment in trying to reduce water
leakages and similar you know we're not
going back to the 70s there's been a lot
of investment since then where uh there
wasn't money put into infrastructure but
nevertheless i'm conscious that we all
need to
do our bit and indeed the water
companies need to continue to do their
bit to reduce unnecessary leakages and
to make sure that we have enough water
so when people turn the taps on it isn't
the problem uh liz tross has committed
to the net zero target but
on the other hand she's also called
solar farms the most depressing site she
won't rule out more north sea drilling
um and she's talked about or she's
planned to to scrap
the the green levy on our energy bills i
mean it sounds pretty inconsistent well
i think it's about having a monitorium
on the green levee which adds about 150
160 pounds to people's energy bills and
to fund uh elements of that through
general um spending rather than putting
it on energy bills so that's one way to
help households directly with the cost
of living particularly the challenging
time but i'm very conscious i'm mp in
the east of england uh going through
these challenges right now with whether
it's about farmers or households and it
is a problem and that's why unlocking
regulations so we get more investment
into things like reservoirs into
improvements to water supplies those are
the sorts of things by if we can get
more private investment in by getting
rid of some of the european regulations
that we have those sorts of things will
start to make it easier to secure that
investment and have that long-term
approach
in improving our water infrastructure
but also other utilities as well okay
there's coffee we appreciate your time
this morning thank you very much indeed